الصلاه والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد
فقد وصلنا في هذا الكتاب المبارك
وفي هذا السفر العظيم
الى وصول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الى
المدينه المنوره
وسميت المدينه المنوره اذ تنورت بوجود
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم فيها
واصحابه
وهذه المدينه التي وصل اليها هي كانت اول
مركز ودوله اسلاميه شرعيه تحكم بامر الله
وتقضي بحكمه سبحانه وتعالى
وبارك الله سبحانه وتعالى لاهل المدينه
وكانت المدينه
يستوخمها كثير من الناس يعني اذا وصلوا
الى المدينه اصابهم حمى ومرض لان الجو في
المدينه يختلف كثيرا عن الاجواء التي بمكه
وفي جنوب الجزيره العربيه
فدعا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم للمدينه
ودعا بحمى المدينه
فصرفها الله سبحانه وتعالى عنهم
وكذلك
دعا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان يبارك
الله سبحانه وتعالى في مد المدينه
وفي صاع المدينه
المد والصاع من
يعني
يكفر الله سبحانه وتعالى البركه في قليلهم
ومروا
بمصاعب لكن الله سبحانه وتعالى
بارك في المدينه وبارك لاهل المدينه الى
يوم القيامه
في صحيح مسلم يقول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم من استطاع منكم ان يموت في المدينه
فليفعل
وهذا
كسائر الاوامر
والنواهي التي تتعلق بالموت يعني اذا قال
الله او الرسول
مت ها هنا او لا تمت الا وكذا وكذا فهذا
[Silence]
كذلك مثل قول الله تعالى ولا تموتن الا
وانتم مسلمون يعني عيشوا على الاسلام حتى
تموتوا عليه ذلك ان الله تعالى جعل من
كرمه
ومن جوده ان من عاش على شيء مات عليه ومن
مات على شيء فانه يبعث عليه يوم القيامه
وصل النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الى هذه
المدينه
والبركه تتبعه
حيثما حل صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال الله تعالى في عيسى انه يقول في مهده
وجعلني مباركا اينما كنت
وهذا من شان الرسل
البركه الحسيه والبركه المعنويه
تتبعه حيثما حل صلى الله عليه وسلم وهذا
قبل حتى البعثه
فانه معروف لنا قصه حليمه السعديه التي
ارضعته كان صغيرا طفلا لا يريده احد
فلم تجد غيره حليمه
واخذته وارضعته فنزلت البركات عليها وعلى
زوجها
وكانوا في نعيما مقيم بسبب وجود رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
بين اظهورهم وكذلك كان الشان في المدينه
كانت المدينه مظلمه يقال لها يثرب
وحل فيها رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وبالتالي حلت البركه وحل النور في هذه
المدينه العظيمه لها مناقب كثيره
من مناقب المدينه ان الله تعالى جعلها
حرما
ومن مناقب المدينه البركه ومن مناقب
المدينه مسجد
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم المعروف
بالمسجد النبوي
وضاعف الله سبحانه وتعالى
الحسنات وبالذات الصلوات في هذا المسجد
المبارك
وجعله من المساجد التي
التي تقصد للعباده يعني الانسان عشان
يسافر على محل عشان يعبد الله فيه هذا لا
يكون الا لثلاثه امكنه لثلاثه مساجد
ابن عمر يروي ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال
لا تشد الرحال الا الى ثلاثه مساجد
مسجد الحرام المسجد الاقصى ومسجد هذا
فالانسان
محثوث على ان يسافر الى هذه المساجد
لعباده الله سبحانه وتعالى فيها
وكذلك
بارك الله سبحانه وتعالى في طعام اهل
المدينه وبارك الله سبحانه وتعالى في
المدينه بان منعها من ما يعم الدنيا من
المصائب
يعني جاء في الصحيح ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
ذكر ان الدجال
والطاعون لا يدخلان مكه ولا المدينه طبعا
الطاعون المقصود به الطاعون الاكبر الذي
كان في زمن الصحابه رضي الله عنهم وما
بعدهم من السنين
فالطاعون الذي يدخل
ويقتحم ويقتل الجميع او غالبا الناس فان
الله تعالى من بركه المدينه منع المدينه
منها وكذلك الدجال يمكث في الارض اربعين
وذكر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم انه يخرج
من
خيل خله بين الشام والعراق فعاث يمينا
وعاث شمالا
ويسافر في الارض فلا يدع قريه ولا يدع
مدينه الا ويدخلها ثم يقصد المدينه فيجد
الملائكه على ابوابها
سالين سيوفهم
فيرد الى الشام الى المسجد
الاقصى ثم يقتل هنالك في باب اللد فعلى كل
حال هذا المكان المدينه مكان مبارك
وهذه البركه كانت في غايتها في حياه رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
جعل الله سبحانه وتعالى لمن هاجر اليها
جعله مهاجرا اليه سبحانه وتعالى وبارك
الله في جيوش المدينه وفي طعام المدينه
كما سمعنا في الصحيح اللهم بارك لنا في
مدنا وصاعنا كان الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم يبعث السراري
السرايا عفوا يبعث السرايا
ولا يجدون يعني الجيش لا يجد الا تمره
واحده لكل فرد منهم في كل يوم
[Silence]
يبقي
النواه ويمتص ويمصها من الجوع لكن في
العاده جيش ماشي في الصحراء بدها تكفيهم
تمره واحده كل واحد منهم بيموتوا في
الطريق لكن الله سبحانه وتعالى
بارك في تمر المدينه
على كل حال مناقب المدينه كثيره
وينبغي على الانسان ان طبعا يقصد المدينه
يسافر اليها وعاده الناس يسافرون الى
المدينه مع سفرهم الى الحج
ونحن لا نسافر الى قبر النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم اذ قبره ليس مسجدا وليس
مقصودا لذاته للعباده عنده ولكن اذا ما
كنا في المدينه
وقصدنا المسجد وكذلك مسجد قباء اذا كنا في
المدينه فاننا نزور قبر النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
ونزور هذا القبر المبارك مع قبر
صاحبيه العمرين ابي بكر وعمر ونسلم عليهم
ونصلي عليه صلى الله عليه وسلم
وننطلق الى
ننطلق الى المقبره التي بقرب المسجد
ونزور صحابه رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
ونياله الذي يموت هنالك ويدفن معهم ويحشر
يوم القيامه مع اهلي البقيع
ذكرنا وصف بناء هذا المسجد العظيم
وصف بناء مسجد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
طبعا في المسجد كان الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم يتجه في اوائل
اقامته في المدينه كان يتجه في صلاته الى
الى بيت المقدس هذه
وبيت المقدس
الاتجاه اليه
هذا كان من كما ذكر شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله
من البدع التي ابتدعتها
ابتدعها اهل الكتاب كانوا يتجهون الى بيت
المقدس وهذا الكلام منسوب الى بن عباس رضي
الله تعالى عنه وعن ابيه لكن الله سبحانه
وتعالى
اثبت بيت المقدس قبله للمسلمين لشطر
بعثاته صلى الله عليه وسلم يعني مكث
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم والصحابه
تقريبا 15 او 16 سنه وهم يتجهون الى الى
بيت المقدس في صلاتهم يعني من حين ان شرعت
الصلاه الى
سنتين واشي او اقل من سنتين في المدينه
فطبعا الاتجاه من المدينه تقريبا
يكون الاتجاه الى الجنوب اذا كان الانسان
في المدينه
وكان
الناس يجعلون
المشرق الى يمينهم والمغرب الى يسارهم
ويصلون وهذا كان اتجاه الصلاه في المسجد
النبوي
ثم
وهذا المكان الوحيد
في المسجد الذي كان يعني معرشا كان له شيء
من السقف كان يقف الامام جزء من المقدمه
المسجد كان من جريد النخل
شيء يعني يكف عنهم الشمس كف عن الامام
والخطيب الشمس
والحر
ويصلون
وبعض الصحابه عرض عليه
ان يسقف المسجد
وان يبني المسجد مثقفا يجعلوه بنايه مبنى
كامل وعليه سقف رسمي
لكن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ابدا ذلك
وقال عريش كعريش موسى هكذا قال صلى الله
عليه وسلم
فقصد صلى الله عليه وسلم وتقصد ان يجعل
المسجد مسجدا متواضعا لان لان الله تعالى
يقول ليس البر ان تولوا وجوهكم قبل المشرق
والمغرب ولكن البر من امن بالله واليوم
الاخر يعني ليس البر
محصور في المظاهر
يتجه الانسان الى هذا الاتجاه هو بار واذا
اتجه الى اتجاه اخر هو غير بار ولكن البر
ماذا العمل المعنى المحتوى
فالمسجد هو مكان مجرد اجتماع الناس
ومكان مبارك له حدوده وله قوانينه وما
شابه ذلك ولا يعامل المسجد
كسائر الابنيه لكن المسجد ليس مباركا في
ذاته وانما هو مبارك من اهله اهل المسجد
الذين يقومون بالصلاه ويقومون بطاعه الله
ويعمرون هذا المسجد هذا الذي يجعل المكان
مباركا
لكن بني مسجد في عهد الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم وكان محرم فيه الصلاه الصلاه محرمه
في هذا المسجد
يقول تعالى ولا تقم فيه ابدا لا تقم فيه
ابدا
يحكي عن مسجد الضرار الذي بناه عبد الله
بن ابي بن سلول وبعض المنافقين ارادوا ان
يجعلوا هذا المسجد مكانا
يترصدون لرسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
واصحابه مخططون ويعملون
البلاوي والناس طبعا بتهاجر
فالمسجد الذي بنوا انه يتلقوا المهاجرين
ويبثوا فيهم النفاق
ويجعلوا هذا المكان مركزا لمحاربه الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فامر الله به هدمه وحرقه كما
المسجد هدم وحرق
وحرمت الصلاه في هذا المسجد ليش
لانه اهله خبثاء اهل هذا المسجد
المنافقون
بعض افراد اليهود وهؤلاء بنوا هذا المكان
ليس لعباده الله بل لمحاربه الله ورسوله
حرمت الصلاه في هذا المكان
وحل رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم محمد في
مسجده
فكان المكان مباركا فالمسجد مبارك باهله
واما الجدران وهذه مظاهر
وليس يعني هذا انه يحرم
حسين المسجد
خاصه اذا كانوا الناس في زمن
يلتفتون كثيرا الى هذه المظاهر لكن في فرق
بين تحسين المسجد وتزيين المسجد
تزيين المسجد نهى عنه رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم ومنعه الصحابه
وتزيين المساجد كان من البدع التي ظهرت في
اواخر عهد الصحابه رضي الله عنهم
لكن تحسين المسجد فان عثمان رضي الله عنه
كما في البخاري لما
وسع مسجد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم جعل
فيه خشب فخم كان مستوردا من الهند وجعل
فيه يعني اشياء نظيفه جدا وجيده هذا لا
باس به مكان يكون نظيف وجيد وصلب وهكذا
لكن يكون مزين نجعل المسجد تحفه
ومتحف يجي الناس يصوروه وما يصلوا فيه هذه
مشكله مصيبه من ايات الساعه كما جاء عن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لكن في حياته
كان المهم الا يزين المسجد والا
يضخم وانما يكون كما قال عريش كعريش موسى
عليه الصلاه والسلام
ثم
كانوا متجهين الى بيت المقدس كان هذا
المكان الوحيد اللي عليه
عريش اللي عليه يعني جريد النخل
فلما تحولت القبله
في السنه الثانيه من الهجره
وقال الله تعالى فولي وجهك شطر المسجد
الحرام
صار الان بدال ما يتجهوا لشكه الشمال
صاروا يتجهوا لاي شبكه الجنوب وراهم صارت
القبله وين صارت القبله في العكس
فظل هذا المكان المعرش
فهذه تسمى بالصفه
والصفه في اللغه معنى المكان
الذي عليه
المكان المظلل
كان من هاجر او كان فقيرا حتى
تستقيم اموره الماديه كانوا يكونون في هذه
الصفه يبيتون فيها
ومن ثم سموا اهل الصفه
ابو هريره رضي الله عنه لعله اشهر واحد من
اهل الصفه لكن اذا سمعنا كلمه اهل الصفه
عرفنا انه هذا المقصود بالصفه
فلما بنوا هذا المسجد
واسسوا
اشياء وراء النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مع
اصحابه
على كيفيه
دعوه الناس واعلام الناس باوقات الصلاه
هذا شيء كان لازما
يعني عندهم مسجد الان ما كان عندهم مسجد
اول كان عندهم بيت الارقم
يجتمعون فيه سرا في مكه
وبعضهم يصلي وبعضهم يقرا قران وبعضهم
يتعلم قران لكن ما كان في اذان وصلوات
بهذه الصفه
فلما كانوا في المدينه
واستطاعوا اظهار دينهم
تشاوروا في مساله
دعاء الناس الى الصلاه كيف ندعي الناس
للصلاه ونعلمهم بان هذا وقت الصلاه
ممكن واحد يقول ليش ما بس استنوا الوحي
وحي يجيهم
لكن جاء النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وحي عام
واحي العام يعمل فيه صلى الله عليه وسلم
فاذا جاءت ايه عامه
اذا جاءت ايه مثلا عامه تدل على نداء
الناس
وجمع الناس الى الصلاه او الى العباده
واذن في الناس يقول تعالى
حكايه عن ابراهيم كان هو ماذا كان على مله
ابراهيم والله عز وجل امره ابراهيم ان
يؤذن في الناس
فتشاوروا كيف هذا الاذان يكون
هل نستعمل
الجرس او نستعمل
هذا او ننادي بالصوت ام ماذا فوصلنا الى
هذا المكان يقول تشاور رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم مع اصحابه لايجاد عمل ينبه نائم
ويدرك الساهي ويعلم الناس بدخول الوقت
لاداء الصلاه فقال بعضهم نرفع رايه
اذا حان وقت الصلاه ليراها الناس
نرفع رايه يعني علم اذا الناس هم الناس
تراقبون رفع هذا العلم اذا رفع عرفوا انه
الوقت وقت الصلاه لكن شو المشكله في العلم
الرايه
فش فيها صوت ناس نايمين ما بيقوموا عليه
يقول فاعترضوا على هذا الراي لانها لا
تفيد النائم ولا الغافل
وقال اخرون نشعل نارا على مرتفع من الهضاب
فلم يقبل هذا الرائي ايضا
لاسباب السابقه واشار اخرون ببوك
وهو ما كانت اليهود تستعمله لصلواتهم
فكريه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم البوق
مثل الصور ينفخون فيه ما زالوا يعني
الاخوه اللي اجوا من البلاد اللي احتكوا
باليهود بيعرفوا هذا البوق
وهذا البوق الان عباره عن تسجيل كنا نسمع
هذا البوق في البلاد ليله ايش
عند مغرب يوم الجمعه صح ولا لا
تتذكروا يا اخوان
انا الوحيد
يعني كنا يوم الجمعه في الليل لانه عندهم
السبت السبت هذا اشي كبير عندهم ممنوع
يشتغلوا ممنوع يفتحوا محلاتهم الى اخره
لما كنا نشتغل عند اليهود كان يوم الجمعه
نص يوم
مش محبه فينا يعني عشان نصلي الجمعه لكن
عشان هم بدهم يتجهزوا لايش لسبتهم
كان وقت صلاه المغرب
يوم الجمعه صلاه المغرب تسمعه كان عالي
صوته
اللي بتذكر وبالذكر والمهم
هذا البوق كان يستعمله اليهود فكره
والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
لانه يحب مخالفه اهل الكتاب في اعمالهم
هذا في
منتهى الشرع لكن في اوائل ايامه في
المدينه كان يحب موافقه اهل الكتاب فيما
لم ينزل فيه نهي
هذا معروف يعني مثلا وهذا كله من من مساله
الاختبار الذي صار في تغيير القبله
يعني مثلا الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم وصل
الى المدينه
فاهل المدينه
القبائل اليهوديه الثلاثه
اذا كان هو يصلي لقبلتهم
واذا كان هو له نفس الشرائع اللي موجوده
لهم يعني مثل صوم عاشوراء هم بصموه
المسلمين بصوموا الى اخره
فبامكان اليهودي ان ينافق يدخل في الاسلام
نفاقا وشو الفرق احنا بنصلي لنفس الاتجاه
وبنعمل نفس الاشياء فمن حكمه الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان جعل النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يوافق اهل الكتاب في اوائل ايامه في
المدينه
ليش عشان لما تتغير هذه الاشياء ومن اهمها
الاتجاه الى بيت المقدس وانقلب الاتجاه
الى العكس الى بيت الله الحرام
هؤلاء اللي كانوا مختفين
منهم بين اظهر الصحابه ينكشفوا لذلك قال
الله تعالى
وما جعلنا القبله التي كنت عليها الا
لنعلم من يتبع الرسول ممن ينقلب على عقبيه
فلما غير القبله
بان الامر وكانوا وهذه كانت في اوائل ايام
النفاق لانه النفاق ما بلش رسميا الا بعد
غزوه بدر ان الناس خافوا
لكن قبل هيك كان ناس يدخلوا وسووا حالهم
مسلمين او يجلسوا مع المسلمين او يكونوا
في اوقات الصلاه مع المسلمين وهم في
الحقيقه ليسوا بمؤمنين
كان يدخل في الاسلام ويرتد وعشان عشان
عشان يدبوا الشك في صدور الصحابه
فلما تحولت القبله انكشف هذا الامر فقال
تعالى الا لنعلم من يتبع الرسول مما ينقلب
على عقبيه
فعلم بمعنى ان الله سبحانه وتعالى راى
هؤلاء واعلم
المؤمنين بهم
في بدايات ايامه في المدينه
الامر العام
انه يتبع مله ابراهيم
واليهود والنصارى بشكل عام هم على مله
ابراهيم
لكنه من سلاله اسحاق
فكان يوافقهم في بعض هذه الاشياء ثم كان
يخالفهم في كل شيء عندما تحولت القبله
واما يخالف مخالفه رسميه او يعمل العمل
نفسه لكن بطريقه اخرى تختص بالمسلمين
فمثلا يقول اليهود لا يصلون في نعالهم الا
فصلوا في نعالكم اطلقوا اللحى وحفوا
الشوارب خالف اليهود والنصارى
في روايه خالف المشركين
هذه مخالفه رسميه يعني هم يفعلون ونحن لا
نفعل او نحن نفعل وهم لا يفعلون
وثم مخالفه جزئيه مثل صيام عاشوراء هم
يصومون عاشوراء واحنا بنصوم عاشوراء وهذا
يوم خير مش شر عشان احنا نخالف فيه وله
امر مباح بل هو يوم معظم عند الله لكن
احنا بنخالفهم في طريقه الصوم هم يصومون
يوم عاشوراء وبس احنا بنصوم عاشوراء
وتاسوعاء او يوم الحادي عشر يوم التاسع
والحادي عشر بنضم اليه تصير يومين وكذلك
هم بصوموا لمنها تطلع النجوم
يهود لا يفطرون حتى
تتضح النجوم في السماء
واما المسلمون فانهم
يسارعون فيه الافطار اذا ما غابت الشمس
وهلم جره
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كره هذا البوق
تقول المؤلف لانه يحب مخالفه اهل الكتاب
في اعمالهم واشار بعض الصحابه باستعمال
الناقوس
والناقوس مثل الجرس الكبير وهو ما يستعمله
النصارى فكرهه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ايضا
واشار فريق بالنداء
فيقوم بعض الناس اذا حانت الصلاه وينادي
بها فقبل هذا الراي
قالوا خلاص الافضل انه احنا النادي للصلاه
يصير نداء
ثم جعل الله سبحانه وتعالى من صحابته من
يتولى هذا الامر
جاء في السنن ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول الامام ضامن والمؤذن مؤتمن
هذا فرض كفايه الناس تذهب
يكونون في اعمالهم يكونون في نومهم لكن
هذا المؤذن
خصص نفسه وخصص وقته لفائده اخوانه بانه
ينادي ما يغفل عن النداء ما يغفل عنه
اوقات الصلاه
فخصص النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بعض
الصحابه بالنداء
واكثر الصحابه اذانا ممن اشتهروا بالاذان
في المدينه طبعا بلاد ابن ربح
وعبد الله بن امي مكتوم رضي الله عنهما
هذولا كانوا مؤذنين رسميا
وكان عبد الله
ابن امي مكتوم الضرير رضي الله عنه تولى
امامه الصلاه كذلك في غياب رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم
يقول المؤلف
وكان احد المدادين عبد الله ابن زيد
الانصاري
فبينما هو بين النائم واليقظان
اذ عرض له شخص وقال
الا اعلمك كلمات تقولها عند النداء
بالصلاه
قال بلى
فقال له قل الله اكبر مرتين
وتشهد مرتين
ثم قل حي على الصلاه مرتين حيا اسم فعل
امر بمعنى اقبل
ثم قل حيا على الفلاح مرتين
ثم كبر ربك مرتين ثم قل لا اله الا الله
والحقيقه الاذان الاذان من اعظم شعائر
الاسلام
والاذان يحتوي ويضم
عموم رساله الاسلام يعني الذي يتعلم
الاذان
ويعتقدها ويؤمن بها فانه المسلم ثم قال
يقول فلما استيقظ توجه الى الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم واخبره خبر رؤياه
فقال انها لرؤيا حق
رؤيه صالحه
ثم قال له لق بلالا فانه اندى صوتا منك
يعني عنده ايش صوت عالي يستطيع يوصل الصوت
وبينما بلال يؤذن للصلاه بهذا الاذان جاء
عمر بن الخطاب يجر رداءه يعني مستعجل جاء
ايش
يقولون يجر رداءه يعني ما لبس مزبوط حمل
الرداء وطلع
فقال والله لقد رايت مثله يا رسول الله
حصل معاه نفس القصه وكان بلال ابن رباح
احد مؤذنيه بالمدينه والاخر عبد الله بن
ام مكتوم وكان بلال يقول في اذان الصبح
بعد حي على الفلاح الصلاه خير من النوم
مرتين واقره الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
على ذلك وكان يؤذن في البدء في البدايه من
مكان مرتفع ثم استحدثت المناره اللي
بيقولوا لها المئذنه او الماذنه في لهجتنا
هذا هو الاصل انه كان ما كان في ميزنه على
مسجد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم وانما كان
يصعد المؤذن الى اعلى المباني التي تكون
في جوار المسجد ويؤذن من على هذا المكان
المرتفع ثم بعد ذلك
استحدثت المناره يعني صار المسلمون
يخصون مكانا مرتفعا
ونسميها احنا المناره
ليكون هذا اندى واوصل للصوت في جميع
القريه
والميادين اليوم
يعني ما الها نفس الاهميه اللي كان الها
في زمنها
يعني زمان كان لازم المؤذن يطلع الدرجات
وبتنظر للميزنه سبحان الله حتى في هذه
الايام
كانوا واحنا صغار كمان الميزنه كانت زي
البلكونه تلف عليها
عليها حديد يطلع المؤذن من الدرجات يعني
المسجد اللي في
بلدنا في السواحل وانا صغير كان الدرجات
يطلعن لفوق مؤذن يطلع بره
يعني هذا مهما لكن الان الانسان بحط
المكبر الصوت على الميدنه او حتى الميدنه
اصبحت مثل العلامه على المسجد
يعني اذا الانسان كان ما بيعرف وين المسجد
هو مار في الطريق راى ميزني وقبه عرف انه
هذا ايش هذا هو المسجد فلذلك استمر عليه
المسلمين ولا
باس في ذلك
نذكر اول خطبه خطبها رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم بالمدينه
استمعوا الى كيفيه الخطبه
في
الخطبه النبويه كانت خفيفه
واضحه كانت في اساسيات الدين
ومعالم الدين العظمى يقول كانت اول خطبه
خطبها رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
بالمدينه انه قام فيهم وهذا حتى كابل
المنبر
حمد الله واثنى عليه بما هو اهله ثم قال
اما بعد ايها الناس
فقدموا لانفسكم
تعلمون والله لا يسعقن احدكم ثم لا يدع
عنا غنمه ليس لها راع ثم ليقولن له ربه
وليس له ترجمان
ولا حاجب يحجبه دونه الم ياتك رسلي
فبلغك او الم ياتك رسولي فبلغك
واتيت كمالا
وافضلت عليك فما قدمت لنفسك
فلا ينظرن يمينا وشمالا فلا يرى شيئا ثم
لا ينظرن قدامه فلا يرى غير جهنم فمن
استطاع ان يقي وجهه من النار ولو بشق من
تمره فليفعل
ومن لم يجد فبكلمه طيبه
فان بها تجزى الحسنه
عشر امثالها الى سبع مئه ضعف والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
كلام راقي جدا
وواضح وعليه معالم كلام رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم ثم خاطب رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم مره اخرى فقال ان الحمد
لله
احمده واستعينه
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل
فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له ان احسن الحديث كتاب الله
تبارك وتعالى قد افلح من زينه الله في
قلبه
وادخله في الاسلام بعد الكفر
واختاره على ما سواه من احاديث الناس انه
احسن الحديث
وابلغه
احب من احب الله
احب الله من كل قلوبكم ولا
تملوا كلام الله وذكره
ولا تقسو عنه قلوبكم فانه
من كل ما يخلق الله يختار ويصطفي قد سماه
الله خيرته من الاعمال
ومصطفاه من العباد
والصالح من الحديث
ومن كل ما اوتي الناس الحلال والحرام
فاعبدوا الله
ولا تشركوا به شيئا
واتقوه حق تقاته
واصدقوا الله صالح ما تقولون بافواهكم
وتحابوا بروح الله بينكم ان الله يغضب ان
ينكث عهده والسلام عليكم هكذا كانت الخطبه
في العاده بين يدي رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم حث على قله
الكلام في الخطبه وكثره القراءه في الصلاه
فان خير الكلام كلام الله فقال صلى الله
عليه وسلم
ان قصري خطبه الرجل
وطول صلاته مائنه على فقهه يعني علامه
وجدت الرجل خطبته قصيره
وقراءته طويله فهذا يدل على فقه هذا هذا
الرجل وانه
ممن يفهمون عن الله سبحانه وتعالى لكن
طبعا
الايام هذه ثم اشياء اخرى تدخل في الخطوه
يعني احنا مثلا
في امريكا هنا
عندنا لغات اخرى لازم نحكيها لازم نترجم
لاخواننا الذين لا يحسنون العربيه وكذلك
شرح الكلام لا بد ان يكون واضحا الناس
ابتعدوا عن علم القران والسنه
فاصبح التفصيل
في الخطبه مساله مهمه حتى يستفيد
حتى يستفيد الناس
الخطبه تطول شيئا عن هذا لكن
باذن من رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
كمان نخلي في بالكم انه الايام هذه الايام
التي نحن فيها الناس ماشيين على الساعه
ناس ماشيين على الوقت اللي عندهم
فبيعرفوا الخطبه من هذا الوقت الى هذا
الوقت والصلاه من هذا الوقت فهذه مساله
مهمه لضبط
مساله الخطبه والصلاه ان شاء الله نكتفي
بهذا القدر والله اعلم صلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين جزاكم
الله خيرا